hello and welcome to the Deo playing G
bianchi from Brazil and the score is not
71 but in fact 1.5 versus 1.5 and so
we're still some way to go um okay let's
go for a benoni playing the 92 93 line
it's an interesting sideline that I have
employed successfully perform now why
does covering the e4 pawn rather
reliably pop and place it a little bit
like as image but with the power on f2
sometimes helpful because you have a
four-in-one move on um can save on that
move all together
yeah I have a soft spot for this move
somehow attacking the pawn which she is
ignoring uh-huh so now I see he actually
well it should be 6 h-4 now ok I see
that sets decent fun ok that's it's
interesting probably that this is a good
reply to show before maybe he's got H
for now aged 49 age 19 h 5 some kind of
some kind of tactical strike ok not
going for it I think I'll retreat this
voluntarily so that after age for I have
night of f2 yeah it's not clear that i
need to smooth edge for i can also play
Queen d2 he wants to go for g5 in this
position ok
hmm yeah maybe Queen d2 would have been
more precise after all
let's bring this back into the game
i also had bishop age six but i wasn't
sure that this helps okay now i'm going
for that now it's very unlikely that he
takes and to be honest let's pit of a
silly pre-move okay this is why i wanted
to go for that it looks looks promising
i think so nigeria says check this is
not so inviting Bishop t4 okay let's
fire let's just fire I mean I'm not sure
about it at all of it playing some kind
of Mick move in these types of positions
is normally leading to problems you want
to play aggressively and in blitz you
sometimes cannot be sure if you if you
play it right you just have to fire them
and hope for the best queen is six I was
thinking 95 might be an option okay
again again 95 not sure 35 you might
have a form
if I go nite Fe for he takes it tough
it's very tough okay but I think he he
basically has to take a for almost I
don't think I don't see a different
movie m 9 f8 or something I'm
threatening f5 p.m. strategically I
think he has to take yes hmm ok and now
if I take with the Queen he has his
check and then f5 so check I thought I
should take and I'll take with this 23
but I'm attacking f7 here right just
drew f1 or stir something better ok
let's go look everyone yeah so 95 is
this the move or not
what is this idea actually bishops is
six or what then i have d 7 so I just
I'm just stepping out of the checks here
the Queen III Queen D for checks Bishop
c6 i have d 7 okay i don't i'm not sure
that 95 is actually the size of it it
looks great but is it a win Queen to f2
let's do this
takes just rook takes time morning yeah
so should I retreat the bishop that
looks weird whoopee one doesn't look
yeah maybe so giving the Queen now I
don't know how to how to play this
position i went there and i can take out
six right d 1 is protected Queen age six
maybe or magic e6 I guess Wow tough very
tough to play look at it I have this one
it didn't help him so much
let's keep the pawn queen is six or
Queen to e7 check 20 seconds yeah
winning now we've got 18 seconds oops
come or and check black resigns I have
typically tough game in the bodoni even
if you have a good position it's
difficult it's difficult to be sure
because it's always summer Kim ok so I
went here and now no f4 looks looks
dangerous at least yeah yep he says good
game yeah definitely it was it was an
interesting game how to how to evaluate
really yeah I went for this for this
most aggressive move now you just have
to play it and hope for the best in a
blitz game so here in d6 Queen e6 it's
probably not so great i was thinking
Knight e5 hear the engine wants to play
this and essentially says white wins
which I'm not quite understanding
I mean I've got far more pieces in place
on I'm not surprised at that white
should win but I'm not really sure what
the point of roo ke one is the engine
wants to do this but ok now so I was
intending this move and thought I should
be fine here but if I was interesting I
but then f five is good Wow check yeah
that's a big Fork yeah it's still very
murky ok he went back this was kind of
logical he takes chat leagues all this
looks normal yeah idea white is winning
with rook f7 aha I didn't consider that
move yeah it's not exactly difficult sad
to be honest he has to go here now rook
e1 is mopping up quite nicely Wow nope
didn't see that one that looked kind of
normal and all these seven wins I saw
the idea but I thought I can pile up
even more but Bishop d7 ok King edge one
wasn't the best lightly five was was
good I was thinking about this move but
I wasn't sure if I'm winning here now
and he has this this heaven seems to
window now kind of inhuman like this
movie ok but King edge one I mean ok
it's blitz chess you cannot play
perfectly left to this one I went here
a computer says this is equal now if he
takes h6 now amazing it gives this in
the equal position poor Jim may be very
difficult they're here why Jessa quite
substantially better I 94 was stronger
but okay Chang yeah that night if for
wasn't the best move I was reasonably
sure but I only had 20 seconds and I
wanted to play something simple rule get
one is strong and threatening who gave
six black doesn't seem to have a defense
against that Luke f7 I just play
strengthening moose yeah this is
securing the back rank so that d7
becomes a threat if I go d 7 immediately
then look 27 kind of hangs on a little
bit because here I'm getting made it
okay I can't played this however it also
wins it also wins okay it also wins
there because of the game continuation
here yes no square for them for the for
the rook this is a bit tougher but also
also winning provide yeah okay tough
game thanks for watching